Hey,
what's going on it's Bill Burr.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before a Friday,
Monday morning podcast.
And I am just checking in on you.
Okay.
This is a very somber podcast.
I'm fucking,
it's not somber.
I just have to go do a show and I don't fuck up my voice before I even go out
there screaming like an idiot.
Um,
I am in clear Lake Iowa right now.
I am about to do the surf ballroom,
the site of the final buddy Holly big Bopper,
uh,
Ritchie Valens show.
I just landed in the airport that they took off from and subsequently died.
I don't know if you heard about that.
They died along with some music I believe.
And um,
okay.
Yeah,
I told a lot of people that was flying into there.
I was like,
dude,
what are you out of your mind?
Well,
good luck dude.
Good luck.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
They don't say that when you fly out of lax.
Right.
Some fucking more on flew his plane into a commercial airliner at La when the
guy was on final.
So,
I mean,
I don't understand what the deal is.
The reason why they are plane crashes because they didn't have the technology
back then.
There was a,
they had ice on the wink.
Okay?
Not only adding weight to the aircraft,
it changes the shape of the fucking wing so it doesn't produce the lift you
need.
And then you've got the big bopper in there.
He's a big guy and a,
you've got yourself a problem.
All right?
Now we all know that I've been off the booze,
I've been losing weight.
So I'm flying in,
I'm not flying in,
I'm riding in and I'm in a prop plane coming down from Minneapolis.
And of course,
you know when you're flying commercial you look at a prop plane like,
dude,
what the fuck?
You know?
But uh,
if you just knew how much the plane probably costs,
I don't know.
Probably too,
it's probably a $2 million plane.
All right?
They can seat 10 people.
Now if you just look at that like what if I own that?
What if I owned one of those?
I have,
if you had a 10 passenger fucking plane,
you are the shit.
Everybody's like this guy he's doing,
he's going to fucking play.
He's got to play in.
What does it hold 10 people get the fuck out of you.
That guy's crushing it.
But the second you fly commercial and it's a 10 seater,
everybody gets all fucking freaked out.
Like I'm not getting in that piece of shit.
The exact same plane that if your buddy down the street went and bought it,
you,
you would think that he hit the lottery.
All right.
A lot less mute moving fucking parts.
So I get on the thing and I immediately texted a buddy of mine who was fucking
terrified of flying just to watch,
you know,
I was,
I really wish that he was there,
a buddy of mine outside of comedy.
So I'm taking the picture as the lady who's going to fly it is doing the,
uh,
the announcements,
telling us basically what not to do.
And uh,
he goes,
dude,
there's no fucking way I would be on that plane.
And then he saw the woman's face.
He goes,
is that the pilot?
And I go,
yeah.
And he goes,
no,
no.
He said,
not for females.
Fucking unbelievable.
What do you mean not for females?
And she doesn't have to bench press it.
It's a fucking machine.
Jesus Christ.
And because of guys like you,
she probably went through extra bullshit to become a pilot.
I think she's going to be fun.
She crushed it.
Of course,
not for females.
Um,
I dunno.
I'm sure some women will be offended by that,
but it really just had to do with this person's fear of flying.
You know what I mean?
He wants,
you know,
he basically wants to pilot,
I don't know what to look like to look like fucking Lee majors of some shit.
Um,
and to be honest with you,
most of them don't because they sit up in that uncomfortable chair their whole
life and they got a quick turnaround.
So they run in there and eat airport food.
And a lot of them,
the lot of them look like,
you know,
if they didn't have like that,
uh,
they actually,
you know what,
if you went to a buffalo wild wings and you took the average football fan,
you know,
draft kings,
fucking Jalapeno poppers,
fucking loud moron and you took that fat fucks Jersey off and you put on a
pilot,
you put them in a pilot uniform and he told you flew for American,
you'd believe it.
You know,
not saying that the average pilot is,
is dumb is he average dope that goes to a fucking sports bar,
myself included.
I'm saying that they have the same body type.
That's all I'm saying.
All right,
so anyways,
you don't think that was fucked up is that um,
I guess it's probably a number thing.
There was only 10 of us including the pilot and is one of those flights where,
you know,
they,
they got like weigh your bags,
all of that shit.
They tell you where to sit,
you know,
the whole weight and balance thing.
And then one of the passengers gets to set up in the copilot seat.
And I was just thinking like,
that's the only part about this that I don't like that there's only one pilot
here.
Uh,
you know,
flying commercial,
there should be two people in case somebody has some sort of cardiac episode or
a or whatever.
Right.
That was the only thing I was concerned about,
but it was a course.
It was a cloudy day and all that shit.
Um,
but,
uh,
it was incredible.
So anyways,
um,
I think I might do this podcast in two parts because I'm so excited to be
playing this venue here tonight.
I'm here with Dean del Ray were freaking out that we're going to get to play
this place and it's still the original stage.
Most of these places,
they don't have the original stage because whoever was legendary who played
there didn't immediately go out,
get in a plane and then died.
So immediately that place became like this shrine.
So they,
they,
they've added to the stage,
but the wood flooring is the same.
And like,
we're going to stand on the same fucking ward.
I don't know if you're into that type of stuff.
Um,
I am.
So I'm very excited.
I guess everybody's ever played there as signed the wall.
I'm going to try to take pictures that they let us know.
So,
um,
but either way I'm going to come back and,
finish out this podcast after I do the show.
Um,
by the way,
um,
I hope you guys enjoyed that live podcast as much as I did.
Uh,
got a bunch of compliments.
People really liked it.
I definitely want to do another one.
Um,
it was weird.
I felt like I was doing standup,
but I was just sort of sitting down on the couch and,
um,
and I was also like amazed at what people laugh at.
You know,
I had,
you know,
I,
I just been doing it,
talking to myself like I am right now forever.
I have an idea what you laugh at that,
but I had no idea how much you guys laughed when people wrote in and shit all
over me.
Um,
when they,
when they ask advice and,
um,
and then the level of crazy shit that I say on here,
just being a fucking moron,
I had no idea that people laughed at that.
I just pictured,
I always pictured,
I always picture guys snickering and then their wives shaking their heads
walking out of the room.
That's what I picture when people listen to my podcast.
I didn't realize,
you know,
we had,
we had a nice mix of people there,
although they,
oh my God,
I forgot to tell you this.
There was this one group of ladies who went to the show that would just hell
bent on letting me know that their friend didn't laugh once,
right?
Oh,
how did I feel is a great story.
So I'm standing there,
I'm taking pictures,
right?
Fucking,
uh,
you know,
signing the posters and all that shit for everybody who came out to the podcast.
I'm being a great guy.
I'm a make God.
I could've just done the fucking show and I could have hidden the green room
afterwards being like,
I'm too tired.
I don't want to meet people,
blah,
blah.
I don't want to do it because I was in Reno and that guy reached in for is a
camera that time and the loaded glock fell on the floor that he said,
oh shit.
Quickly picked up and ran out of the fucking place.
I didn't,
I walked out there and I was being a good guy.
Right.
So these,
uh,
these older ladies,
right.
Um,
older meaning they're probably about a year younger than me,
a year or two younger than me.
You never know.
It's very hard to guess.
A woman's age,
a white woman's age,
you know,
you can't tell.
You know what I mean?
Because they're not big on using lotion.
And after you have a kid like that does something to you,
you know,
see,
as a guy it's hard because as long as we take care of ourselves,
we don't have to go through given birth.
You know what I mean?
Although we do have to live with women,
I may,
maybe it just all kind of washes out.
I don't know.
Anyways,
I think they will roughly my age.
Um,
and also I wasn't in like a,
I was in Phoenix and Phoenix is a,
yeah,
there's enough plastic surgery there that people give a shit what they look
like.
Some of these cities you go to like,
you know,
like do you ever like watch old movies or old TV shows in the 70s and you'll see
somebody or you look at a picture,
one of your favorite actors when they're 25,
it's like,
dude,
that guy looks like a 40 year old.
Like what 25 used to look like compared to where it does not well,
when you go to smaller towns,
those people age the way people used to age.
Yeah.
Like Lucille Ball going from I love Lucy to the Lucy show.
She looked like she did it 40 years later.
She went from having this really nice voice to be like,
I miss the Modi.
I like fucking smoking camel on filters.
Whatever the hell she did.
Um,
I dunno.
But anyways,
what the fuck is my point?
So these ladies come walking up.
All right.
I could have just said they were about my age.
Right.
Which means to fucking old.
So they would just say,
hey,
you know,
you said that question,
you,
you know you wanted,
I was saying guys,
you need to be honest.
And they was,
I think they,
I think what happened was I think that they didn't like what I said about the
woman that found out she was banging this guy,
we had a wife and family.
I don't think that they,
I don't think they liked the response to that.
So they came up cause they seem like they wanted to make me upset
cause they came up and they were going like,
yeah,
just to let you know,
she,
she didn't laugh once.
She didn't laugh once and I left cause that's funny,
right.
I was just like,
oh I'm sorry.
Right.
And she goes,
yeah,
I liked just stand up but that podcast live podcast,
I don't know about that.
And I only like,
oh alright.
And she goes,
yeah,
cause like I didn't laugh once and I was like,
all right.
And then they were going like,
yeah,
and you said to be honest.
And she didn't laugh once.
I was just like,
all right,
cool.
So I mean,
what do you want me to do?
I mean I had an hour and 20 minutes to make you laugh.
I didn't make you laugh.
I mean,
I'm sure as hell not going to do it standing there.
So I don't know what they were looking for.
And they just kept hammering that fucking point
going.
You said you said you wanted,
honestly,
we're just being honest.
I say I appreciate it.
It's fine.
You know?
And then I finally just said,
look ladies,
like everyone else was laughing and then I kind of made a motion around the
woman who wasn't laughing.
I was like,
I can survive this.
And they all went,
Ooh.
And I'm saying I wasn't shitting on her.
Yeah.
I just always look at it like the president of the United States.
Okay.
Like w I went in there,
there was like four or 500 people there.
One person came up and said that they didn't like it.
So just to make round numbers,
we'll say 399 out of 400 people enjoyed it.
Okay.
If a president or a senator had that level of approval rating,
I mean it would be unheard of on fucking hurt him.
So I'm going to walk away thinking that was a win.
And um,
okay.
You know,
I dunno,
they just,
oh,
they just kept coming over,
but she didn't like it.
She did not like,
and that's the greatest
thing you can ever do when anybody criticize you.
Just be like,
ah,
no wait.
I want you to feel the weight of me not liking it.
Um,
I should have asked,
just giving her a refund.
How would she pay for the tickets?
Sweeter.
Alright.
Tell you what,
I'll make a deal.
I will give you that money back and whatever else it takes to get these fucking
hands away from me.
Good Lord.
I,
I'll,
I was trying to think,
what did I say that made them take it to that level?
Because there's no way
if they were with some guys,
I would think,
all right.
They got dragged to the show and they were like,
who is this fucking animal now?
That's happened to me a million times.
And then I sheepishly apologizing.
It's like,
sorry,
I'm a moron.
Um,
but they came there by themselves,
which means they liked me before they went there.
So either she truly didn't laugh.
Ones truly did not like it because she just didn't think I was funny or
somewhere in there.
I pissed her off.
I think it might've been that,
you know,
I'm going to say,
uh,
it was either the married woman thing,
the ovarian cancer,
the dead first wives in the snow and Aspen,
I'm gonna say somewhere in there
she decided that she needed to tell me
that she didn't.
Last ones didn't laugh once.
I have to tell you,
it kind of made my fucking night though.
Um,
every,
once again,
I can't say every once in a while.
Well,
it is every once in a while now because I don't go out there,
but man,
I,
oh,
oh God.
I had some fucking,
I can't,
I'm so old now.
I can't even remember the amount of fucking times.
Especially a lot of women too cause I,
I went through a bad period but a good,
I don't know,
I'd say like 12 year period out of my 25 just really trash and women in it just
really was just my fucking issues.
Um,
I'm trying to think what the fuck.
I just vaguely remember being in North Carolina
and this woman was walking up to the table and it was fucking hilarious or
boyfriend or husband was like holding her back.
He looked,
he was water skiing behind her.
She was drunk or whatever.
I came and what the fuck she was saying cause it was such a spectacle watching
that guy trying to hold her back as she was like climbing forward it,
you know what it looked like.
It looked like,
you know,
like wartime footage when they like split up families.
It looked like she was trying to get back to her child like that.
That was the level of effort that she was making just to come up to me to tell
me how much of a fucking model moron she thought I was.
And,
uh,
that was a good night's comedy.
I do remember that.
I just don't remember what I said or what she said.
I had that one,
this is weird.
They're all coming to their like faceless,
like they're like,
you know,
like when you watch like psycho,
when he comes in with the knife and you can't see his face,
spoiler alert,
you can't see his face.
Um,
that's what they kind of looked like to me anyways.
I don't want to dwell on this shit any longer,
but,
uh,
anyways,
if for whatever reason,
if that woman who didn't laugh once is still listening to this,
uh,
I dunno.
I Dunno what you want for me.
I would,
you know something,
I would go to the all things comedy network.
We have plenty of podcasts.
I'm sure there's something else that you could find there.
By the way,
the podcast network,
uh,
the all things comedy podcast network,
the first annual,
um,
podcast festival was a smashing success.
We got rave reviews from everybody came out.
I really want to thank everybody.
And then also Irish affair who was just sort of the mayor of the podcast
festival where he got in Thursday,
he jumped on everybody's podcast,
teach us,
was used just the fucking greatest guy ever.
Um,
so anyways,
with that,
how can I go this far into my podcast and not mention the first world
championship ever by the Houston Astros?
How great is that?
That was such a great thing.
That was as great to see as it was sad for la.
Yeah.
I'm telling you,
you gotta hate that somebody has to lose a game.
Seven is just brutal.
I was actually sitting there thinking how cool it would be to actually see magic
Johnson.
He's got an NBA NBA ring and a world series ring.
This does anybody,
a sports nerds,
anybody know anybody out there on both of those rinks?
I'm thinking back in the day,
maybe somebody won the football and the baseball.
That was like a big thing for you or two sport guy in those sports didn't really
overlap that you could possibly win two titles.
Um,
but,
uh,
I don't know about a fucking stomach is growling,
trying to stay in shape,
but like three more days in this fucking movie.
So you wanna fucking days.
I actually,
I actually brought in a Caesar Salad.
I'm going to say that one more time.
A Caesar's salad.
Okay.
And I always want to do that because I love when people start yelling at you
about the amount of calories and the dressing and the crew tons and Yada Yada
and all of that fucking Shit and how you might as well have had a steak.
Um,
I think all of that is bullshit.
Okay.
She's still have the lettuce with all the fucking,
you know,
pesticides on it,
I mean,
that's a decision you have to make right now.
Do I want to eat a cow that ate another cow,
was with hormones in it or do I want to eat this thing that was sprayed by DDT
or whatever the fuck is in this shit.
Um,
the end of the day,
if you're gonna eat bad,
if there's a fucking salad,
I mean I'll go with the cancerous pesticides as probably worse to eat one of
those things,
but I don't want to hear this shit about the fucking dressing.
I didn't want,
I didn't want to fuck,
I don't hear a word about that.
Okay.
Cause I know I feel after I eat is fucking Caesar's salad versus how I feel if I
eat a steak,
you know,
with a couple of sides.
The Fuck Outta here.
That's it.
That is it.
I'm fucking grabbing at my pants like Matt Foley
and I,
I have a gut for like three days after that.
Um,
I know it's all fucking bad for you.
Who gives a shit?
I just need to hit the elliptical.
Um,
I started my physical therapy for my rotator cuff injury finally.
I don't know why it took so long.
Like how long if I do that,
he goes through these exercise three times a day.
I go,
when should,
when,
how long should it say sky's like when I was six weeks typical German,
Irish,
stupid freckled count.
I've been dealing with this for a year and a half,
like an asshole.
I could've just gone to somebody,
a goddamn physical therapists.
This is,
yes,
we deal with this all the time.
This is what works.
Do this
see in a week.
So I'm very excited.
My shoulder actually feels a little bit better.
Um,
although being out in this Iowa,
whether,
fortunately I checked,
um,
I check the weather before it came out here,
cause I wouldn't,
you know,
live in an La,
you don't think it's just endless summer out.
They sometimes you forget what time of year it is.
I actually brought a pea coat out here and I gotta tell you it's fucking killing
my shoulder to put it on and off.
Um,
had had dean helped me put my coat back on after we ate the worst fucking,
the worst fucking meal I've had since I was with Dean del Rey again when I was
in Wyoming and we ate and this little diner.
And I think that the short order cook wasn't there that day.
And I wanted two eggs over easy.
They came,
they were like clear.
It looked like fucking breast implants with Yolk in the middle of it.
What?
This fucking Guy Brian.
I still ate him cause I was hungry.
I remember the waitress came by,
she was just like,
was was that all right?
And I was just like,
yeah,
it's fine.
And um,
this time we were walking a,
I can't even tell you
the name of the airline that we fucking took in here.
I don't even know the name of it.
It was,
it was a play on like air force one
like the president.
Hang on one second.
Let me see if I can find this shit.
Oh fuck you pot.
All right,
here we go.
Here we go.
Andy.
Uh,
to the,
what the fuck is it?
When a fuck is my,
you don't want it didn't want us on the plane.
I deleted like a hundred fucking text messages.
You know,
you have that thing like,
oh my God,
I can't delete it.
If I deleted then I don't have the thread like you're trying some case.
I just started deleting a bunch of them,
you know,
it felt good.
All right,
here we go.
What is the name of this fucking thing?
Air Choice One.
Yeah.
You know,
we couldn't even pre check in for this thing.
You had to walk to the gate.
We were in Minneapolis and it was just like,
we just kept walking.
And why don't know why we didn't take the little monorail thing.
We just kept walking and walking and was in concourse B,
which was like you went down some stairs and walked underneath the fucking
tarmac or some shit
to get over to this other side.
And uh,
but it was still cool as shit.
And then when we landed in like the mid city airport,
I think that's what's called,
I don't know what the fuck it's called,
but it was a cool as shit airport.
You just walk right in to gate agents.
This like 12 chairs down near the baggage claims.
I love little airports.
Um,
anyways,
so we were,
we're on our way over there and I had the worst fucking
food that I've had since when I was in Cheyenne,
Wyoming.
And I know that place is better than what it was.
I just was went there on a bad day.
I'm not shitting on Wyoming.
I'm not shitting on Cheyenne.
All right.
Um,
I got the meatloaf with the mashed potatoes.
Okay.
All right.
And Spinach and a,
and I wanna hear when you talk about red meat and a starch,
everybody knows it's shut the fuck up.
All right.
I like potatoes with the meat.
I don't give a shit.
So they put this mushroom gravy on top of it.
I swear to God it tastes,
I don't know.
It tastes like somebody just took an aerosol can and sprayed it.
It had like a chemical taste to it.
It was so fucking bad.
I was like,
Dean,
tasteless,
tasteless.
Seems just,
you know,
just like,
what the fuck?
I was like,
I know.
Then you know what fixes everything?
What is the duct tape of food?
Huh?
Like if you're in construction,
right?
If you have a problem,
duck it,
right.
You take out the duct tape,
you fucking,
you know,
wrap it around a few times and you find what is the duct tape of food?
Everybody,
we all know it.
We all love it.
Salt,
salted the shit out of it.
Salt couldn't even help it.
I had to go for ketchup.
I had to put salt and catch up on this fucking,
I just finally had to tap out.
Um,
and I always,
whenever the waitress comes over says,
how was the food?
Even if it sucks,
I say,
how are you going?
You see shows I always at,
I always say it was good.
It was good.
Thank you.
Um,
I even said it was good when I had the breast implant fucking eggs over easy.
Right?
And this was the time I was going to be like,
if she asked me how this is,
I'm going to say this is,
I'm,
I'm just gonna say this tastes like,
this is like,
I dunno what,
like,
like homeless,
like you some homeless guy soak his feet in it.
I was actually just sitting there waiting for the waitress to come
thinking,
how can I accurately describe how fucking horrific.
And if you're in Minneapolis in Minneapolis and you're going to take air choice
one airlines,
there's a fucking restaurant right to the left brake before you go down the
escalators of don't get the meatloaf with the gravy.
All right,
spoiler alert.
Okay.
Oh my God.
What was it?
Chemical is the only way to describe it.
It wasn't like,
what is that ingredient?
You're like truffle oil.
Truffle oil is fucking obnoxious.
It just,
it just overwhelms anything that it's on.
It's never always there.
Truffle oil in here.
It's how much truffle oil is in this fucking thing.
It's undeniable.
This taste.
I,
you know,
yeah.
I wish I could've brought it to one of those cooking shows.
You know,
those fucking guys would like [inaudible] women.
They got like those pallets going,
okay.
Okay.
Um,
I'm tasting a little Oregano.
and uh,
there's chocolates or like those of noxious cigar videos with those Douche bags,
those fucking Douche bags
sit there smoking a cigar.
That is one of the most like,
Ugh,
one more sec noxious things you will ever see.
Put on a youtube video and watch a guy do a review of a fucking cigar.
I fucking hate I when they see that this chart,
I'm tasting chocolate.
It tasted chocolate in the smoke.
You Fat.
Fuck.
What did you just go to friendly's.
He needed Jim Dandy.
Who the fuck tastes chocolate?
What do you you,
you fucking smoke at one of those cigars that they have dipped in like that
sugary shit you've ever at some fucking guy with his sweet tooth gives you a
goddamn cigar.
Yeah.
You got to go to like the dentist the next day.
All right.
I gotta I gotta pick this up.
I gotta go.
I'm actually a couple of minutes later,
I'm,
when I,
when I returned,
I will tell you what it was like to perform at the legendary surf ballroom for
me.
It's giving me an hour and a half for you.
It's going to be a mere second
and a bag just like that.
Just like that.
Two seconds of your life.
A good fucking,
uh,
I don't know what that was.
Three,
four hours of my life.
I just performed at the serve ballroom.
Clear Lake,
Iowa.
Um,
unbelievable.
Yeah,
one of the coolest and and also like a spooky as places I've ever performed at a
,
so here's the deal.
You dry,
you pull up,
it looks like
it looks like it's from the 1950s you walk in the exact same door.
They all walked in and there was this little green room area.
It looks like they used to be a bathroom back there too.
They kind of just got rid of that and they had a couple of sinks I guess that
they use to some shit.
And everybody's autograph these walls and I'm sure that that's like the fifth
time they probably painted over the party paint over like once every decade.
And they just keep like these big people like a
Willie Nelson,
Merle haggard,
Waylon Jennings of course.
And then all these other people I saw,
you know,
all the guys from like skid row,
bunch of bands that I knew from the eighties and nineties,
early nineties that I used to listen to do faster pussycat,
all of them.
Uh,
who else?
Just a whole bunch of people.
So anyways,
you go out there and I'm telling you man,
it's like this giant.
Yeah.
Looks like it's not a happy days.
And what they did is they had the original stage and then they built out from
the original stage.
But some women a number of years ago actually had photos from that night and she
found them all these years later.
So you can actually tell where the stage was.
So I made sure when I was up there,
I walked all the way back to what they have.
Like the phone where Richie Valens and buddy Holly made their last phone calls.
It's really,
I mean it's,
it's,
it's this weird thing of like,
like,
uh,
an incredible part of history and like really morbid.
MMM.
I Dunno.
And I'm always interested in that type of shit.
And then it's also weird,
like I went to Elvis's house and I remember going in there,
I was a young comic and I wanted to go in and laugh like,
oh,
look at his shag carpet with the folks up with Elvis.
And I went in there and I actually felt bad after awhile.
I was like,
I'm going,
I'm in this guy's house.
This is what this guy used to chill out and shit.
I feel like,
you know,
this is uh,
and then the end,
you walking by his grave and shit,
it's like,
can we just leave this guy alone already?
Cause they haven't,
they made enough fucking money and then you go across the street,
there's a gift shop.
They literally made a cuckoo clock,
you know,
is it looked like his,
his hips will move it and shit.
But the way they did it here was very like respectful.
But um,
it's Kinda hard to not feel like a little bit of a Google when you go there.
I'm a little bit of a Glenham death is,
is interesting.
You know,
dead rockstars are interesting.
They're all right.
And I was interested in,
I went and I got to perform there and stand on the stage.
It was fucking amazing.
And everybody coming out in the show was fucking crowd was awesome.
I'm telling you all you fucking elitists,
liberal cons,
who live near an ocean,
you'd think you're fucking,
I dunno what you're really missing out.
All right.
And all you redneck fucking my pig one first fucking blue ribbon in the fucking
who gives a shit contest.
You're missing out by not going out into the coast rights.
Everybody fucking grow up cause there's fun to be had out there.
You know what I mean?
MMM.
You know,
it was funny when I was on the plane ride over,
this woman's going,
I was like,
she's like,
it's one of the most friendliest places.
Everybody waves.
Hello,
everybody is just really friendly out here.
You know,
of course,
in my head I'm thinking,
yeah,
if you're white,
I'm not seeing
a black guy can't come out here.
But if a certain amount came out here,
you know,
and they weren't going to fucking play for Iowa or Iowa state,
there'd be some issues.
Um,
you know,
it's,
I don't know why,
but that's the way the world is.
All right,
let's,
uh,
let's do a little,
oh yeah.
And then we came back to the hotel and ran into this fucking guy and he came up
to me,
he's gonna let people keep saying that,
you know,
I look at,
look like yet I love being fucking shit faced.
And I was just like,
I would take that as an insult.
I go,
you're a better looking version of me.
Just,
you know,
big,
tall drunk guy.
He just compliment just fucking whatever he wants to hear.
Get him the fuck away from me.
Right.
But it's still funny guy.
And he just,
he was very like,
uh,
talked with his hands and shit.
And he was just this giant 20 years younger me with hair.
And
I finally just,
I couldn't take it anymore.
I finally just said to him,
I said,
dude,
you're hammered.
He goes,
what?
I go,
you're hammered.
He goes,
hammered.
I go,
hammered
cause I'm sorry.
And he walked away.
Oh,
what a great,
oh,
what a great bar was.
Oh,
would I have loved to sat down and had a couple of SAS Barilla's but I didn't.
77 days in 77 re book 77.
Paul Coffee,
77.
Nate soldier,
uh,
77,
fucking led Zeppelin tour.
All right,
let's read some,
um,
advertising here and then I'm going to fucking upload this thing here.
1125 central time.
All right.
Dollar Shave Club.
Everybody.
Dollar Shave club a,
you've heard me talk about the amazing shape I get.
I got from my dollar shave club razor,
especially when I use it with their doctor cabbies.
Easy Shave.
Well,
I'm here to tell you I'm never giving up my membership.
In fact,
I'm adding even more dollar shave club club products to my daily routine.
The fuck are they talking about?
I'm too stupid and figuring out how to get a membership.
Yeah.
You know what I did use after tonight?
Uh,
I fucking ate some chicken wings and I used a one wipe Charlie.
Cause Dean del Ray had one supposed to be for your ass,
but it works for your face to just be sure no one used it on their ass first
year.
Right.
Dollar Shave Club makes products for your hair,
face,
skin,
shower,
uh,
everything you need,
they make you look good and feel amazing.
And it's all their own original stuff.
They only use the finest premium ingredients and they deliver it right to your
fucking door just like they do their raises.
That means no more annoying trips to the store,
cruising up and down the aisles looking at all the stuff from the shelf.
What the hell is this?
What do I do with this?
Um,
you know,
it'd be,
even less annoying is less copy.
How fucking long is this?
Um,
okay.
You can use dollar shave club from us.
Everything.
Razors,
body cleansers,
Hair Gel.
And now's a great time to give dollar shave club a try.
You can try your first month of their best razor along with their travel size
versions of the fucking,
she found a body cleanser and yes,
even the butt wipes just for five bucks.
Come on,
you cheat.
Prick.
You know better.
You look,
the more likely you're going to get fucking laid right after that.
Replacement cartridges,
cartridges ship for just a few bucks a month.
It's the dollar shave club started set.
Get yours for $5 exclusively@dollarshaveclub.com slash burr that's dollar shave
club.com/burr a right?
Okay.
Oh No,
these guys,
I got strict instructions not to bring up their competition during the read.
[inaudible]
lift.
Everybody lift.
I'm not talking about the 80s and just fucking bench press in and doing curls
and doing you Tris and doing your shoulders and never doing squats.
That was the easy A's.
I'm not talking about eighties working out,
laying on a fucking tan in bed with you.
Little chicken wings and you fucking Middle Linebacker,
upper body.
I'm not talking about that with you.
Big Thick fucking aerobics socks,
right?
You macgyver haircut you David Hasselhoff hair cut.
I'm not talking about that when I'm talking about as a ride service.
Lyft,
l,
I.
F.
T.
Lyft knows that their drivers are what?
Keep them moving.
They do everything they can to make sure that their drivers are happy on every
trip.
Lyft is the ride sharing company that believes in treating it's people better.
I believe if elected lift believes that being,
there's a lot of beliefs here,
believes in being a ride,
sharing dry,
that being a ride sharing drivers should be fun.
If you're having a good time,
so are the passengers.
Wait,
don't enjoy yourself too much there buddy.
He got my life in your hands.
They're okay enough with the jokes.
Turn around and look at the fucking road here.
Lyft was the first to offer in ad typic.
When you drive for Lyft,
you keep 100% of the tips.
Drivers have been paid over $200 million in tips since the feature was
introduced.
Express pay lets drivers get paid almost instantly instead of waiting for weeks.
Lyft has even taken the guesswork out of pickups.
The new amp device uses color coding to help pass.
Just find their drivers.
You can earn hundreds of dollars a week plus tips.
One,
earn more money,
drive more.
It's never been easier to give yourself a raise.
It's a simple formula.
Happy drivers mean happy passengers.
Maybe that's why nine out of 10 Lyft riders get a perfect five star rating.
Plus people usually to mean to say that they stunk.
Kind of like how you know I was finally going to say something about that
fucking meatloaf with the mosquito spray on it.
So joining the ride sharing comes.
So join the ride sharing company that believes in treating people,
treating gets people better.
Go to lift.com/bird today and you can get a $500 new driver bonus.
That's lyft.com/burr
lyft.com/burr limited time only terms apply.
Did Tarantino,
right?
These how fucking long in these be even he at least had a little overtures,
some shit in the middle,
right?
Or did that begin?
I Dunno.
Pro Flowers.
Do you have any of those people who are,
if you know any of those people who are obsessed with fall,
things like pumpkin spice lattes and scented candles.
Pro Flowers has the perfect gift.
A pistol with one bullet in it?
No,
I'm sorry.
Pro Flowers has a perfect yet I long lasting both bouquet and their favorite
fall colors there.
Best selling cinnamon cider roses are a great option for birthday and
anniversary or any fall occasion or go with one of the classics like 100 autumn
blooms or it doesn't.
Autumn roses you can't lose because no matter which bouquet you send my
listeners,
you send my listeners,
get 20% off of any pro flowers,
unique bouquets for only $29 or more to get 20% off all the bouquets or $29 a
more.
Go to proflowers.com and use my code [inaudible] at checkout.
That's pro flowers.com and code burr.
Okay,
I'm just going to pause here because I don't think they ever really listened.
Why would you have autumn?
This is off the record here.
If I can just speak off the record here.
Why the fuck would you have an autumn theme with flowers?
That's when everything fucking dies,
right?
It doesn't make any fucking sense.
All right.
He likes everybody [inaudible].
There are a ton of online mattress retailers popping up these days.
All with a one size fits all solution to a better sleep.
Well guess what?
One size fits all doesn't fucking work.
All right?
I don't give a shit what those other mattress companies tell you,
okay?
He looks helix.
They know what they're talking about.
He looks sleep opera,
something that doesn't exist anywhere else.
Um,
mattress personalized to your unique preferences and sleeping style that won't
set you back thousands of dollars.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash Pir way your junk.
Find which way it swings when you go to rollover and they'll have a little
fucking pill that sewn into the mattress to catch it.
Okay?
Sorry.
A mattress personalized to your unique preferences and sleeping style that won't
set you back.
Thousands of dollars.
Go to a helix,
sleep.com/burr.
Take their simple two to three minutes sleep quiz of somebody who had the right
debt.
Why don't we do a benefit for that fucking person?
They're always talking about people who have diseases.
What about the person has to sit down and come up with a fucking quiz about a
mattress is what I went to college for.
This is why I'm buried in debt.
They'll build a custom matte.
Despite people drink,
they build a custom mattress.
That will be the best thing you've ever slept on.
For couples,
they even personalize each side of the mattress,
which we all know is the beginning of the end of the fucking.
I just feel like we're not connecting everyone from Gq to cosmopolitan to New
York Times.
We're all talking about helix and once you try it out,
you'll know why.
Your customer mattress arrives direct to your door in a week and shipping is
completely free.
Just make sure you're home and they deliver it so someone else isn't sleeping on
it and this fucking economy,
try it for 100 nights.
If you don't love it,
they'll pick it up and you and refunded.
They'll pick it up.
Gross and refund you in full CTA must read.
Now let's call to action in the advertising world.
Go to helix,
sleep.com/burger right now and you get $50 towards your custom mattress sets.
Helic
sleep.com/burr for $50 off your order.
One more time.
Helix,
sleep.com/burn oh lastly,
but not leastly,
stamps.com and everybody,
the headliner,
they always go and last.
Stay stamps.
Save you time and money.
Yeah,
you don't have to walk over to somebody.
You can fucking put a piece,
a little thing on there.
And then the person with the little blue short shows up and they take it,
um,
which you make.
Okay.
Which you can use to grow your business.
I can mail any letter,
any package using just to my computer and my printer and mail them in the mail.
Man picks it up.
The mail man picks it up right and mail lady shows up in a little fan,
you know,
all dainty ride.
Sidesaddle avoid,
you know,
pushing the fucking gas and the brake with little selfie stick.
Sorry,
I live in La.
That's how it's done.
Avoid the hassle of the post office man and mail everything from postcards to
envelopes to packages,
domestic or international.
Create your stamp account in minutes online with no equipment to lease and no
longterm commitments.
I use stamps.com anytime I send out any of my posters,
whenever I'm going to whore myself out after my shows,
I am a moron.
If I can figure out how to use this device.
So can you,
and right now youtube,
youtube,
like the band can enjoy the stamps.com service with a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus bonus.
What?
Four week trial plus postage and a digital scale without longterm commitments.
We a go when?
No where you ever see that?
Me a Gif jiff whatever the fuck you call it.
Go to stamps.com click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinbirdthatstampsdotcomenterburststamps.com
never go to the post office again.
What was that Jif?
Remember that something,
uh,
what you,
you know when the woman's like,
where is this relationship going to?
And then they cut to that old p diddy song.
We a go when?
No,
where we a go.
No Web.
Um,
that's it.
All right.
I think that's the podcast.
I had such a great time and uh,
it came out and got to meet a bunch of people afterwards.
A lot of people,
some people came in from Colorado,
people came in from all around.
Um,
just to check out the
venue.
That's what I liked about the show tonight.
I had a great time and I also feel there was a bunch of people that have never
been to that venue venue before.
So they got more than a show.
They also got to see that part of rock and roll history.
Uh,
I mean in the pictures in there,
the people that have played there,
it's,
it's unbelievable.
Before,
you know,
all of those guys
Ritchie Valens at all,
those guys play.
They're like Duke Ellington.
They have a piano that Duke Ellington Plate,
like sitting in the fucking lobby.
MMM.
It's incredible.
And it's beautiful out here and that's it.
I feel like I brought America together with this show.
You know,
I live out in liberal Hollywood where,
you know,
we believe and we know that we are better than anybody else in this country
because we live near an ocean and we make movies about social issues to show
that we care before returning back to our gated communities.
You know,
and we only wish that the rest of the country would catch up with us.
Um,
I'm fucking with you anyways.
That's it.
I'm on my way til two,
uh,
Milwaukee,
Wisconsin tomorrow.
MMM.
One of my favorite fucking cities.
And uh,
I'll tell you all about that on Monday.
And then I'm going up to green bay now.
I was supposed to hang around and go to the bump bump up Monday night football
game.
That's why we booked that one.
MMM.
But,
um,
well actually it's a good thing.
I mean,
I've got an acting Gig,
so I have to leave after the show to do my last three days on a movie called
front runner starring Hugh Jackman.
It's the Gary Hart Story.
Uh,
it's directed by Jason Reitman.
I'm already promoting it.
They're not even done shooting and I'm already promoting it.
That's how great of an employee.
I am.
A,
it's going to come out next year.
I've already seen like the dailies,
it looks,
it looks frigging amazing.
Um,
so I'm not gonna be able to get to go to the game,
but,
uh,
Aaron Rodgers is hurt anyways,
but I've only been to Lambeau field and went there a long time ago.
It was actually,
I've explained this skyline cafe in Appleton,
Wisconsin and
mmm,
Green Bay had a preseason game against the Cleveland browns and Brett Farve was
still there.
That's how long ago this was.
Brett Farve was still there and nobody was talking about him retiring.
It was Brett Farve and,
uh,
he played like the first quarter,
maybe into the second quarter.
So I got to see him play a little bit there.
I know it was just preseason,
so I kind of wanted to go back there for a legit game,
but,
uh,
it didn't work out on this trip,
but,
uh,
it's already been awesome,
so thank you to everybody came up,
enjoy the music.
Uh,
and with them.
List the producer of the Monday morning podcast and Thursday afternoon just Uber
fired him.
More questions.
Sometimes I don't want to say the whole thing.
He's going to play some music here and then we'll listen to you listen to an old
podcast from a Thursday from a year gone by or possibly earlier year and now I'm
done talking.
Go fuck yourselves.
Have a great weekend.
You cunts and I'll talk to you on Monday.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
[inaudible].
It's kind of this his wife.
What's her name there?
Heather Mills.
I'll read this real fast.
It's short a wife to start.
Paul.
It's short.
It was the pot or May.
Yeah.
Listen to this or me.
Heather Mills said she gave Sir Paul Mccartney a strict ultimatum.
As the relationship blossomed,
quit smoking marijuana.
Marijuana.
Excuse me.
Or forget walking down the aisle.
Huh?
I told him I would not get married to him if he was taking drugs.
I hate it.
Heather.
37 told London's observe our newspaper.
I could not have him lying to our child about not taking drugs and then going
out for a sneaky puff.
He says he had a good incentive,
a good incentive to stop smoking pot.
Her ultimatum.
Yeah.
You don't give a beetle and ultimate,
excuse me.
Yeah.
Do you think John Lennon would have taken that?
No.
[inaudible] balcony.
Yeah.
With the one leg.
The way this is given up rules.
Yeah.
It's Paul Mccartney.
You know what?
He obviously didn't sign a prenup because there's no way to take that.
She wouldn't even brought it up.
This was before they got married.
She wanted him to stop smoking pot.
There is no way Paul Mccartney should be taking an ultimatum from anybody.
Especially best what?
One foot.
The second wife,
not even at the one he wanted,
the one he wanted and married.
Died.
She's like the standard plus lean and like for fucking decades.
Yeah.
Someone needs to help that guy.
And he sat there and let Linda Sing on those songs where she is just making an
abortion of of a classic Beatles Song.
Ah,
just an open book.
And I said,
live in that live
[inaudible] is playing,
born here.
The hey Jude,
this.
Oh my God,
I never,
ah,
dude,
oh,
she has such a bad singing voice at the engineer's finally decided to just
isolate her Mike and hit record because there's no real audio from a Paul
Mccartney concert where she was singing background vocals.
I guess they turned her down in the mix,
but this guy said,
this is way too good.
I guys share this with others,
so he a taped just her microphone.
I'm guys.
Hey Jude as being a song.
I'm guessing she was probably kind of contacted to the guy and started actually
thinking that she was actually a museum.
Probably was just like,
all right of the band.
I bitch.
Yeah,
yeah.
Oh,
I'm sure she probably,
you know,
they knew she stunk and I get more based on my monitor athlete.
Yeah,
I can hear what with the fucking plane.
She's the one every time looking at the sound guy pointing at her ear and
putting our thumb up like more monitor.
I can't hear me louder in the mix.
[inaudible] mixed you those air phones.
That one we won over and their phone number,
their tone and holds him
[inaudible]
this is the real deal.
Listen to it.
Yeah,
no,
this is actually Linda Mccartney.
You'll think this is a joke.
This is so,
this is the real deal.
Listen to this.
[inaudible]
yeah,
Nah
isolated.
[inaudible] what else on this list I'm hitting allege every time
really bad right here.
Listen,
what's so funny,
classic classic song.
This song is almost secret.
Is it any wonder they broke up?
No one can fuck that out.
We should have put in a shower like Barney rubble.
So,
so,
so I it,
but that visit a shower.
We got a square back then
when the saints come marching them,
we got Bonnie Relo.
Look and listen to little rock.
Listen to a role isn't to the Ebit in mockingbird.
Golden Smog.
Really?
Wow.
Well Grandma's
the mocking bird
and it's under the moccasin votes.
Flip
bogging is wailing his last.
So we've got enough of like Fred,
we also have a yoga,
his legs would be doing like flawed bond down slip and go,
go,
go.
Is dog called
Yoko Ono.
He'll go on and wasn't much better.
You ever see rock and roll circus?
The documentary is,
is known as,
she can't sing?
No,
I've never heard of you,
but she's more turned us onto this man.
You had like an all star band on stage at John Lennon.
Tell me out.
And who was on Mick Jagger?
Ringo.
Ringo is the king of the all star band.
No,
but this was like nine drummers.
Someone's got to help us out here.
No,
this was the finale finale.
So it was a John Lennon oxidation with Mick Jagger.
Eric Clapton Guitar,
Jimmy Hendrix Guitars.
Yes.
Back had to be there.
No,
that's it right there.
The Wha wha what about the Ho no,
that was part of the whole part of the show.
But if this way valley matrix was alive,
this is,
this is where they pretty much like just a dental appliance.
It's rugs got together and just Jan's.
But the final song is what I'm getting at.
Yeah.
It was Lennon on stage with Mick Jagger,
Eric Clapton Guitar and Hendrick's guitars.
And they just,
how can you fuck that?
Fuck that.
Allegence.
So listen to Yoko Ono erectus thing.
It was the,
uh,
the final song of this rock and roll circus.
That documentary,
who has a,
Derek has it.
Did you fast forward a little bit or,
okay,
listen to this.
So they're just jamming away,
right?
There's Y'all gospel
sound
like
hope guys.
That is a both at guys.
There's an APP on her foot.
Cubic can't make that sound like Jimi Hendrix still play.
Like he wouldn't stop and got bar located.
Do you think Lennon,
you're Hendrick spaces or something,
but one of them know like Clapton should,
it just turned around and gone to John.
Your fucking lies.
How old?
The fluffy I'm going to whine about it.
Hit her over the head with a guitar.
It's awful.
I know I'm not,
I'm not available hot or this whole thing.
What do you know?
She is a spool.
[inaudible] man.
Call this program.
What is this shit,
man?
I don't know what,
yeah,
it's a little known fact that took Eric Clapton nine years to tell his friend
John Lennon that he was in a disaster.
Irish.
Yeah,
exactly.
Like this.
Sounds like I don't know how to bring it up.
I just don't know how to bring it out.
Nice.
I go,
Gee,
we're doing a little call back.
Call back.
[inaudible] why couldn't anybody who's helped me before I got divorced that she
stunk?
Have an eight.
Your fucking life.
Miserable human being.
I want to use the new signals.
Get together songs at the local pub.
How is that?
She sounds like this sounds like a napalm strike on the Ho Chi Minh trail.
That's what it sounds like.
Just screaming Vietnamese children.
I cocked.
Wow.
Let's do a David,
Texas.
Hey,
hey.
Hey Brad.
Brad's like,
oh my God.
Linda Mccartney went up.
I been told her she was walking out the parking lot one day.
She saw this truck driver had a McDonald's bag on the floor of his trucks.
Fired his ass on the spot
for eating McDonald's.
Wow.
Can we can do it,
dude.
I mean,
there was no,
no meat whatsoever
there fucking shot at his door was open.
You know,
we're all standing there.
She's like,
who's truck is that?
That is,
you're fucking gone.
Like,
oh,
no shit.
Unbelievable on the page.
I told you I love you guys are listening you all every morning out here on tour.
I'm punching out.
All right,
let's go to Randy in New York.
Randy on Yo,
what's up guys?
Hey,
yeah.
Going a little back before.
Do you think Paul Mccartney was using a,
her leg is a bond lid.
Oh,
smoking's the other pas.
That's how this started.
But that's where the ultimatum was to stop smoking out.
Out Out of my lane.
Mills is telling a beetle pot where may,
how about uh,
me smoking pot or you gimp your ass out of here and try to find another beetle
lottery.
Who's been nice.
Lottery does.
One left got Pamela Caringo you idiots.
It wasn't for drugs.
We wouldn't have had the second half of the Korea.
Sergeant Pepper's all that.
Right.
It's drugs.
Yeah.
Drugs that did that,
thank God.
And earlier a girlfriend and give the same ultimate and we wouldn't have all
that stuff that came out.
I wanna hold your hand.
Pick the Beatles.
Wouldn't you think would they would have been like,
like one new gone down in history as much?
Yeah.
It would have sounded like the Hanson brothers started smoking on be wasted and
put here that those satin majorette fucking outfits on.
So they sang a song called the yellow submarine.
Just
take them free drugs though,
isn't it?
No,
no,
no.
There is a definite line when they discovered drugs and it is so apparent and
now someone is telling Paul Mccartney to lay off the plot.
Yeah,
I'd still have some of this in.
I'm still one little puff and all of a sudden a brings out,
it's hidden.
It's a brilliant song coming out.
Remember me?
Yeah.
Smoke your pot.
She's pitching at him.
Find another beetle.
Go ahead.
That's amazing.
I wonder why he is he too pussy to go?
Um,
let's,
let's be honest here to see this house you're living in.
And that was because I was smoking pot with my pals,
smoking pot and doing a lot more.
I would just leave where I cut down.
I would just be in the house and go off and answer.
Let me show you something.
Echo,
Echo.
You see that shit.
That's the living room.
I will do whatever the fuck I want to do.
I just put him in the leg.
Just listen.
A
champion,
a ham,
Fox fucking captain Ahab Ndm and knew a lot of money.
Look,
I'm just constantly pointed her foot.
Nobody,
no one's hot enough to be missing a limb when I'm,
I'm,
I can get,
uh,
he,
I bet you Paul Mccartney could get a 21 year old dude.
He met you.
This is not by South beach.
Yeah.
This isn't even an issue that you have to say.
I bet you he can.
He's Paul Mccartney,
the Beatles this into,
there's only two left.
You just sit there right when she's,
when she's talking shit to you,
you just,
you just shake your head back and forth like mm.
Mm.
And you just keep looking at her until she said so.
And she,
and you just keep going.
As you'd shake your head,
look at it.
I didn't look at her foot once again,
but Theresa will just something,
she can't come out.
They set up,
these are going to go.
And
um,
which one is it again?
Back to the,
I'm on a second.
And then knowing it and then knocking on the fake one.
Um,
hello.
I'm a Beatle.
Bitch.
Who fills your closet with left shoes?
Paul?
My fucking fucking baby.
That's your last name.
Bitch.
My fucking Courtney.
How about the,
and you know what?
I'm going to give you a new one of those new wooden legs in the shape of a joint
just
to it ashy like it was fucking
going to say one end from somebody sucking on it.
Paul.
A fucking Carnaby's joint on the side of it.
Let's go to Frankie on whales to rim shot.
What's up?
Crazy.
Okay.
See that's where
Paul made a mistake.
Uh,
uh,
an album called rubber soul.
Heather Mills happy about an album called rubber sole
it off my mind.
Relax and float down stream.
I'll hold your hand.
I never thought of that in my life that she loves you.
Yay.
Yay Paul.
From a job in it.
But wasn't that part of their greatest hits you?
Oh yeah.
I mean it's hindsight looking where they went.
They came out as like,
they came out,
they were like in sync,
but the boy band of Liverpool,
they weren't handsome in one hit wonders when that fucking came out though.
They was
[inaudible] they were done.
Yeah.
That stuff was,
they will dry out if they didn't,
if they didn't listen to Peter Noone listen to Peter Noone stuff who didn't
progress on to Henry the eight.
Yeah,
and they really hate that he was,
he just dumb.
He might've been addressed and he's like,
second verse,
same as the Ame and radiate Siam.
It's just like
[inaudible] midnight runners should Islam [inaudible] to something.
Go Stat guy does some things,
you know,
walking around one eye's a thousand of those guys and bad guys,
but they never went on the smoke with pot and take the LSD and shit down with
the Maharishi and fucking get hammered.
Even thought of that Shit,
man.
Let's go to Paul Jersey.
He's got something.
My Paul Paul,
Hey Paul Mccartney,
his wife can have a full term pregnancy.
Whoa,
wow.
[inaudible] beat the foot.
Wow.
Oh my goodness.
Look at Erin Smith.
Erin Smith in the 70s completely wasted.
That's the best fucking music,
best shit.
Then they get cleaned up and you get love in an elevator.
You got to,
they got their most commercial success though after they got off the drug,
so let's go to which is weird.
I know,
man.
Stick with the pro drug fucking slant or the show.
That is for the instant feedback bit ruining.
You did.
What did I do?
I ruined your Beth.
That's ready.
The band.
You got me bash.
Jesus.
You motherfuckers.
Y'All are just,
Oh,
we don't forget.
we don't forget and
we don't get back to Sicily.
He is laid at a time.
You open a dro.
Let's go.
You killed my father drove.
Yes.
Go.
Hey Man,
what's up?
I got the MacArthur,
the ultimatum about two weeks ago.
Well,
I potter me,
but you're not a beetle.
Yeah,
I know.
So you're not smoking pot anymore.
Fuck that.
They got to go buy another bag today.
There you go.
Alright,
let me blow it up and blow and blow.
We'd rings in a face because I was like,
he's on pot right now.
We're talking a Beatle.
He should be able to take her leg off and beat her over the head with this.
Right.
You should still come back with a loving smile or turn it into an instrument
like the,
yeah,
the the thing that you do,
fucking trombone that you had to come over.
[inaudible] watch.
This means I'm a,
I'm a car holes in it.
I'm gonna turn this to a big flute.
You're leg is a giant
playing her leg and I want you to play your leg and some smoking to enhance my
eye and seeing the back.
I want you to sing the chorus,
the yellow submarine.
Why smoke weed?
All your legs.
We are
[inaudible].
Hey,
what's going on?
It's built bar and it's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
November 2nd,
2009 can you believe that?
It's November.
Oh my God.
Where's this year?
God.
Jesus.
Every year it goes by faster.
I know.
I always do that joke,
but that's what everybody says.
Can you believe it's November?
Yes,
I can.
You know what gave it away October.
That was the big hint that fucking November was coming up.
You know,
Halloween.
I remember that.
I know that's on the 31st
so yes,
I can believe in.
Yes,
yes.
It does go by quicker.
Obviously it goes by quicker.
Think about it.
When you were a child,
you know,
if you were four years old,
if a year went by,
that was 25% of your life.
Yes.
So it definitely dragged on.
Plus you had two giants telling you what the fuck to do all day and what to eat
right.
And when you're 41 years old,
a year goes by.
That's like a,
it's kind of math.
I can't do,
I don't know what that is.
What does that one,
one 80th of my life,
you know,
it's funny.
It's actually Sunday night right now,
and I just settled down to do the podcast.
I had the apartment to myself.
I'm thinking,
all right,
can bang out a nice hour and all of a sudden the windows open and I hear
somebody driving by listening to this song,
this is how we do it.
It's Friday night,
blah,
blah.
I'm like,
who the fuck would still be listening to that music?
And Lo and behold,
it's the woman I share my life with,
pulling in,
listen to a song that sucked when it came out on the radio.
Bullshit.
You listen to that station all the time.
All I want to do with chromosomes on Zomato bone bone.
You're up.
Yeah.
See?
He listened.
He listened to all of that shit.
You listen,
I'm going to pause.
I'm going to get satellite radio so I can listen to really bad hair metal and
you can know what the fuck I was listening to.
You know what you smell like right now?
You smell like that overpowering air freshener that you put in the fucking car.
I smell something different.
What did he smell like?
Yeah.
Huh?
It's it's,
I don't know what it smell it get away from me.
I got to do a podcast.
I can't be smelling smells.
What is it?
Yeah.
What's the name of it?
What?
Exotic fragrance and get away from me said,
okay,
well then I'm going to stick with that.
Then gather your belongings and get out of the room.
So you guys,
this is how you handle a little more when they deliberately act moody.
You just said get away from me and I'm really rude.
No,
I didn't.
I said a comical way.
If I see if I'm holding a microphone with an orange fucking windscreen,
you can't take it seriously.
You can not take it seriously.
No Way with being an asshole.
Yeah I do.
I get away with it.
What?
I don't want to cause I'm running shit.
Get out woman.
Go make me.
You see here,
which will make me say which,
Oh beat it.
Come on.
I want to talk about Halloween and how I thought we had the fucking the best
shit on the block.
But yeah,
he's fucking assholes up the street.
All right,
let me back up near.
You need to walk so I can tell this story.
All right.
You and your fragrance need to get out of the room here for a second.
Okay.
La.
Oh,
she just smelled her wrists and goes,
I like it.
I had giant Athan fuck you.
Oh,
that's how you keep it fresh people.
It's the fights and then the making up and whatnot.
Um,
why did I just do that through,
cause I was annoyed.
I thought he had the apartment to myself,
so I just decided to be a Douche.
So there you go.
I'm Douche bag of the week.
Um,
I pulled it out the last seconds.
anyways,
so for Halloween,
those of you who are longtime listeners of the podcast know that I,
I'm,
I'm kind of into Halloween.
I like it.
I decided to embrace the holidays a couple years ago rather than just being
like,
dude,
this is fucking bullshit.
It's used to know the corporate fucking straight.
You give me [inaudible].
Um,
I find just said,
you know what?
Fuck it.
So,
um,
you know,
last year,
if you guys are on my myspace page,
so I'm sticking it out there.
I have pictures of the Pumpkin I carve last year I carved an ACDC pumpkin.
That was the shit.
Okay.
It was the shit.
And this year as in like,
how do I top this?
And,
um,
I was trying to think of the scariest thing I could think of to carve into a
pumpkin.
And I ended up carving the,
uh,
the Federal Reserve Bank.
Okay.
I know I'm going crazy.
I can still smell that fucking fragrance.
It's overpowering,
whatever it is.
Oh God,
it's awful.
Jesus smells like flowers and soap all at the same time.
You know,
one of those things individually,
they're good,
you know,
like brushing your teeth and orange juice,
but if you put them together,
um,
so anyways,
yeah,
carved the Federal Reserve Bank.
It's the fucking shit.
All right.
Uh,
go on,
on my myspace page.
I've got a whole picture of it,
you know,
and then I fucking made pumpkin bread afterwards and I fucking toasted the
seeds.
I was like a native American,
you know,
after I killed the Pumpkin,
I used all the parts.
I took out the Pumpkin's Achilles tendons.
I made a fucking jump rope out of it,
you know,
and I looked out the window,
I saw some trash and I got a little teary eyed and that's what I did that I just
use the crying Indian hacky reference.
That was funny.
Way Back on VH one.
Standup spotlight.
Do you guys ever used to watch that?
Any old people out there?
The standup spotlights when they were just scraping the bottom of the barrel of
anybody remotely left.
Funny from the 1980s half the people on there were like substitute teachers.
They had chalk on the back of their pants,
come in a little deal,
fucking erasers and they'd somehow we're making money.
You know,
what am I talking about?
So anyway,
so not only do I have the Federal Reserve pumpkin cause I figured you know what?
Anybody can try and scare the kids.
You know who,
who,
whoever tries to scare the parents.
That's what I,
that's why I decided to carve the Federal Reserve Bank and did it fucking three
d style.
It's the Shit I had flames behind it actually tried to carve.
We own you in reverse writing.
So it would come up against the wall,
but I failed just because I don't have,
I don't have the tools.
All right?
All these assholes who are making these fucking insane pumpkin's half of these
cunts,
they just go,
you go on a website and you just buy something.
He just trace it and it tells you what to do.
You don't have fucking third grader could do it,
you know,
and then you get all these,
all these little double edged knives and all this shit.
I had a,
I had a fucking paring knife,
the same knife I use to cut up an apple I carved in the Federal Reserve Bank.
Okay.
And I was going to have wheel on you,
but that part failed.
But whatever.
So I had that.
And then I also had,
I had full size candy bars.
You had your choice.
If you came to my house on Halloween,
you had your fucking choice of a Hershey bar without nuts.
Cause God knows all these fucking pussy kids are allergic to everything.
He can't have almonds,
almonds,
it countered back balances his PROZAC.
And then it's just crazy until Wednesday.
Really Lady.
Did you ever think you should have died and not had a kid?
Wow.
That was mean.
So now what I was trying to say,
but I was,
I was trying to say,
I was talking about natural selection there that Ja,
whatever's in you was so fucking weak that your kid can't even have nuts.
You know what I mean?
I mean,
every,
everybody's allergic to getting fucking stabbed.
But when you're like allergic,
I can't have food.
You shouldn't be alive.
All these fucking people,
all these lactose intolerant fucking people clogging up the highways,
all of you,
you should not be alive.
You're only alive because,
uh,
Jesus Christ,
I really talk myself into a corner.
Why Bill?
Why are they alive?
Because of modern medicine.
They're just using you as a fucking revenue stream.
All right,
who's kidding?
Who?
I would've been dead 100 years ago.
I would have been,
I had a ruptured appendix and sixth grade.
They would have been if I would have been on like a little house in the prairie,
just laying there sweating on a fucking 58 blankets and an outhouse is now what
they did with their sick.
You should just stick them under blankets and start dabbing at their forehead.
Does this make it better?
No,
it doesn't.
No it does.
It's something inside of me exploded and now the poison is having a party
and a,
he should take me out back and shoot me like old yeller.
So anyways,
I got this fucking insane fucking pumpkin.
All right.
Okay.
Anybody can,
can,
can carve in some shit that doesn't exist that will scare the fuck out of you.
This actually exists and is actually was actually fucking everyone who's walking
up the stairs,
all of them.
All of them should have been like,
Holy Shit.
That's it right there.
That is the devil.
That is the fucking devil.
I love that Pumpkin.
It looks great.
It's saying something and it's scaring the shit out of me.
It's working on all three levels.
It is a fucking triple threat.
Like,
like the way people used to be in show business back in the day where they could
sing and they could dance and they could tell jokes.
That's what that Pumpkin Pumpkin is,
you know,
that's the,
yeah.
You know all that was,
is what I was hoping they would think.
But they didn't,
I didn't get one comment.
Why did he carve a building into a pumpkin?
I don't understand.
Is that a Walmart?
One of my good,
Walmart's fucking scary.
You know,
somebody came with the stairs who fuckin actually try to start a hardware store
anyways,
so I had fired this fucking insane pumpkin.
All right.
Um,
have my fucking door all lit up and all that type of shit and I got full sized
fucking candy bars.
Okay.
For all these cute little kids coming up.
All right.
But uh,
something,
and this is going to be at,
word's going to get out.
This dude's got a fucking,
you know,
he carved a library into a pumpkin and he's got,
who gives a fuck?
The guys aware of,
everybody's got full size fucking candy bars and their candy bars that we
recognize kit-kat,
her Reese's peanut butter cups or fucking or Hershey.
What does it not?
Hershey,
Hershey milk chocolate.
Okay.
Those were all fucking,
we know what those are.
So even though he's a Weirdo,
it's wrapped.
We understand there's no poison and so I'm thinking I'm going to be the shit.
These kids are going to be clamoring around me like I'm fucking Dick Clark in
1965.
Right.
But no,
I got fucked because the people up the street,
they were,
they went all out.
This dude up the street,
his son and daughter,
his son fuck head that he is now his son and his daughter put on a show like uh,
like Michael Jackson.
They were doing a tribute to Michael Jackson and it was fucking insane.
They had a stage,
they had like monitors.
It looked like a fucking rock show is going to happen and they had a show like
every 20 minutes or every half hour and a whole crowd would gather.
I didn't even get to see it.
I was down the street with my full size candy bar.
Am I fucking new world order pumpkin going with a f where is everybody?
You know I got a fucking seven 11 here.
So what are this in my fucking kitchen look like?
Literally like I robbed the seven 11 and rather than taking the money I took all
the candy out of it.
That's what the fuck it looked like.
And I,
and I can't get a God damn fuck it.
I can't get anybody to come cause everybody's running up the street cause these
kids were killing it.
You don't kneel.
Went up there with their mom and they came back.
Oh my God.
It was awesome.
They even had the car from the fucking whatever video and he literally got in
it,
Blah Blah Blah.
Just wanted to fucking slap both of them.
Um,
no I didn't.
I want to,
I was fucking pissed.
I was literally reduced to yelling off of my balcony going as people were
walking by to go up to go see the Michael Jackson thing.
I was going,
hey,
we got kids here.
We've got candy up here.
Right?
Think about the 41 year old white male yelling down to children that he's got
candy.
It was really,
it was really bad,
but,
uh,
eventually I got rid of all of it and uh,
I discovered a new,
uh,
pet peeve that I have.
Um,
I don't like trick or treaters who look like they're fucking 26.
All right.
You know who you are.
You're too fucking old.
It's not cute anymore.
You know,
you're a Douche.
And um,
the last group of people came up as was fucking unreal kid had a better mustache
than I could grow.
You know,
he didn't have a mustache,
you know what I'm saying?
If you're too fucking old.
And he was actually saying she fucking hates them too when she wanted to do was
have a bag of apples.
And when people came up and they would do it too old,
she wanted to give them apples instead of candy.
I'm like,
yeah,
that's great.
And then they get down to the front yard and they throw it through your fucking
window.
Why don't we just hand out baseballs?
But I understood what she was talking about.
You know,
the fuck is wrong with you.
How old are you?
Okay,
you should be going to a Halloween party trying to fuck somebody dressed like a
tube of toothpaste or whatever it is.
That's what you supposed to be doing.
You're not supposed to be coming to my door.
Fucking yell.
Was it knowing I should have had a little bite size ones.
Anyways,
so I actually was walking my dog this morning and I was seeing all like the
candy wrappers on the ground and all the fat kids who couldn't wait til they got
home.
And um,
and um,
I dunno,
they will all bite size.
None of them were full size.
I the best candy on the fucking block and I got trumped,
but it's Vegas show up the fucking street.
Really?
I don't know.
It was just annoying.
No,
I just shit out of me.
And I also,
uh,
I,
when I walk my dog,
I actually,
I,
I pick up litter because a,
I think I live in a nice neighborhood and I don't like when fucking people throw
shit on the ground.
So I'm sitting there picking up these little candy wrappers,
my Goddamn Dog,
and uh,
came across a milky way that that bugged me.
You know,
we do,
you know why even give out candy if he'd given out a milky way,
that's such a fucking cop out.
It's like,
uh,
I can't,
I can't even fucking gives a fuck about Holland.
You don't Milky Way.
The Milky Way is like,
it's like
if John Oates was a candy bar,
he be,
he be a fucking Milky Way.
That's what I'm trying to say.
All right.
If you don't listen to fucking hauling out cheating,
you don't get the joker right.
He at something it knowget new get is John Oates.
Okay.
Nougat needs some sort of,
it needs something with it.
You know what I mean?
It's like a Andrew Ridgeley who some of the other famous duos that broke off and
one guy just totally fucking made it and the other guy was the human fucking
version of,
of new get with nothing in it.
Can you think of anybody else?
I know fucking in sync.
Justin Timberlake was the almonds.
Those other four mother fuckers.
That's what they were.
When Justin was in there,
it was a snickers bar.
You took him out as a Milky Way and nobody fucking gave a shit.
And that was the end of them.
That was the fucking end of them.
Who gives out Milky Way,
you know,
fucking you not even try and not even fuck.
I had full sized fucking candy bar and I was,
I was hanging out screaming at people trying to get them to come up to my
fucking places.
Pathetic.
But I'll tell you right now,
the pumpkin bread was to shit.
All right,
let's move on here.
Um,
let's talk about my life.
What I have going on.
Um,
I'm trying to hype shit that I have going on,
um,
earlier in the podcast.
So here goes this week.
I'm going to be a town hall in New York City.
I'm not the town hall,
the town hall theater.
And um,
I don't even know if there's any tickets left,
but I just like saying I'm going to be doing a theater in New York City.
Do you realize that?
Do you realize how huge that is for me?
You know,
way back in the day when I was a youngster with a big Red Afro,
wondering if I'd ever get on stage in New York City just to do five fucking
minutes at one o'clock in the morning,
you know,
and here it is,
38 years later,
I'm finally getting to do with theater and I'm actually really excited and um,
I'm doing my special next month and um,
you know,
this is going to be,
weren't basically,
if you go to that show,
you're going to see basically my special essentially.
So I got that going on and a,
that's November 6th of November 7th,
I'm going to be doing comics,
come home with Denis Leary,
the 50th anniversary.
It's for the Cam Neely,
um,
the Cam Nealy House that helps families,
of people's stricken with cancer gives them a place to stay rather than sitting
in some awful hospital.
They actually get a nice home to stay in.
So that's a wonderful cause that'll be at a guidance arena with a bu terriers
play.
And uh,
I believe there's only a few tickets left for that one.
So that's what I got going on.
And later on the month I'll be in Tempe,
Arizona.
Really looking forward to that Gig and uh,
and the rest you can go to [inaudible] dot com bur for,
for uh,
for dates.
See,
and that's why I don't hype shit in the middle because it's not funny.
It's not fucking interesting.
And uh,
then what happens?
You're like,
what?
This guy's going to riff about fucking candy bars and musicians I don't give a
fuck about and then tell me where he's going to be at.
Let me tell you guys a story.
The other day I decided,
you know,
I really need to get my ass in shape so I don't look like a fat fuck on TV
during my special.
So,
um,
I have problems with joining gyms because I'm always on the road.
I have to freeze my membership and all that type of shit.
I just throw the money away.
So I had been working out outside basically in my apartment and then I do cardio
outside just like that fucking guy with all the Matthew mcconaughey.
There you go.
You know,
I do keep my shirt on and I don't run down the street with fucking palm tree
leaves like I'm trying to fly and it's 1898.
I don't do that shit.
All right.
But I've definitely been going on hikes.
So I found this hill out here and uh,
being a big football fan,
I remember how Jerry Rice used to run up this fucking hill,
you know,
to get in training for the,
uh,
the NFL season.
And I found a hill and I've been running up this fucking thing and uh,
been loving every minute of it.
And um,
I went up to go do it and I came home and my fucking,
I couldn't find my keys
like an asshole.
I left the,
uh,
my pocket open on my sweatpants and because I'm old and when I run down the
hill,
I can't run down the hill.
I have to sort of Gallup,
that's fucking pathetic.
And a,
I was going really fast and I guess it kind of flew out a fucking rattlesnake
took it.
I don't know what happened,
but I went back up there to try and find them.
And I don't have them.
And you're like,
wow,
what's the big fucking deal?
You know?
Why don't you,
Oh shit.
Did I just fucking knock something out here?
What the hell just happened?
Hello.
Test one,
two.
I know you can hear this,
but I can't hear myself.
What the fuck is going on?
Hold on.
Hello.
I know it's recording.
What the fuck is the problem line in?
That's good.
Your phones.
That's fine.
Hello?
Test.
There we go.
I got it back.
Sorry.
Jesus Christ know what is my fucking rooms getting so God damn hot.
I have to turn on the fucking ceiling fan.
Hang on a second.
I can't do this all at once.
You know if at any sort of class,
I'd edit that part out,
but I'm not going to [inaudible].
So anyways.
Yeah,
so I lost my fucking keys and like anybody,
any normal person,
if I had a normal fucking car,
oh,
that's what I did.
I turn this thing down.
That's what happened.
Ah,
there we go.
Hello.
Test one,
two.
Wow.
Just when you thought it couldn't get any worse.
This is why it's free,
folks.
This is why it is fucking free.
Like a one man band here.
I should have like symbols between my legs.
How fucking easy was it to be a goddamn entertainer back in the day that,
that,
that that's what you could have you ever seen one of those one man band guys.
It's never good.
It's never fucking good when somebody does like a throwback to that shit and
they get symbols between their legs and a base drum behind their back.
Great.
I turned the fan on too high and I'm blowing shit off my fucking desk.
Um,
anyways.
Yeah.
So I can't find my keys and um,
you know,
the house keys,
no big deal.
But the problem was was it was also the key to my car and I drive a hybrid and
it's this special fucking key to special key people.
They couldn't just give me a regular key where you stick it in the door and
shove it in the ignition.
This is like one of these keys where you can have it in your pocket and you
don't need to take it out,
and then you just fucking reach and touch the door and it magically unlocks
because some sort of wave is coming out of the pocket,
going to the door lock,
bouncing back off and putting cancer into your testicles.
You know?
That's what I'm basically doing.
I'm risking ball cancer so I don't have to fucking unlike my door the
conventional way.
But the bottom line is you want to,
you're probably wondering,
well bill,
how much does this pocket ball cancer fucking car key cost?
Evidently it's between two two in 300 bucks.
I remember when I bought the car,
I made sure you'd all wooziness Merck,
shrewd,
all losers because we call story tool $224 to park grumble,
blah,
blah.
And I was thinking in my head,
wow,
that sounds like a fucking rip off to me.
Really,
that little plastic thing.
So I don't,
and I went back up the hill and I tried to find the fucking thing and I couldn't
once again,
you know,
I went up there and it's actually really these,
these unbelievable houses like um,
like rich people,
but like classy rich,
not like a,
not Jerry Jones rich,
you know what I mean?
Classy,
tasteful,
rich,
you know,
and I was walking down the hill and I was looking for the keys and I came down
and this is fucking all gay is walking up the street and right as I was about
ready to say hello to him,
you know,
rich people are so like they,
some of them just have the,
they have an inability to lake,
just have a conversation.
It's like I'm walking down the street,
he's coming up the hill,
he sees me and I'm just be like,
hey,
how are you?
That's all I'm going to say.
He just,
this is what,
this is how he greets me.
He just goes,
beautiful fall afternoon.
I didn't know what the fuck to say to that.
And he said it that loud and it took him that like he drew out the words
beautiful fall afternoon.
You know what should have happened right after he said that,
you know,
in those,
the original monster movies of Hollywood,
you know,
that church organ that they,
and then the lightening strikes,
that's what the fuck should happen.
After that guy talked,
it's like,
Whoa,
what are you just naming shit that you like?
Like I didn't know socially what I was supposed to say after beautiful fall
after noon,
um,
half off Budweiser's at a titty bar.
Yeah.
What do you say to that?
I don't know what the fuck to say to the guy and I,
I just sorta went.
Yeah,
yeah,
it is.
It's a nice one.
Just kept fucking walk.
Ugh.
With the fire.
It was like,
I was trying to think like what question I could have.
I was thinking he's playing a board game in his head or he played the first five
notes,
so to a song and I said,
ah,
what is the name of that song?
Uh,
tell me what is it?
It's called beautiful fall afternoon.
That's what it's called.
Um,
anyway,
so I walked back up there and I just kept saying to people,
[inaudible] you have,
is she a shed a quiche?
And they'd be like,
no,
I didn't.
Um,
but if I find them,
I will,
uh,
and I had no information to give him.
And I was just like,
yeah,
just sort of stick them on a rock,
go on a rock.
And maybe I'll come walking by and I'll fucking,
you know,
but I held out hope.
I was like,
you know what,
it's a park.
There's a lost and found.
I'll go there tomorrow when the lost and found is open.
And I went there hoping against hope that for once in my life I lost something
in public and somebody actually returned it,
you know?
Do you remember that from back in the day when I lost my cell phone,
my girlfriend since I been with her has probably lost three cell phones and any
time she loses his cell phone,
all she does is call it.
She calls it.
And not only does somebody pick it up,
it is the greatest
person on the planet.
You know,
I should just call up and I'm thinking my head.
Then I was going to answer this shit.
It's gone.
Just like mine is always gone.
And then she calls,
you know,
one and a half ring.
Somebody just picks it up.
Hello.
Well,
yes I do.
Absolutely.
Come on over.
I'll give it to you.
I actually just bake some cookies.
Come on over.
I'll give you a fresh cookies and your fucking cell phone back because that's
how your life works,
right?
I lose my mind in the back of a fucking car is fucking douchebag is driving me
to the airport.
I realize it like a half hour later.
I know we still working and the phone is on and it's ringing in his fucking back
seat in the can.
Doesn't answer it.
So that has been my experience.
So I go over to the little ranger Rick thing going on,
please.
There may be,
this is the one time keep a positive attitude,
put it out to the universe.
I'm going to get my $200 set of keys back and of course I show up and they're
like,
uh,
no.
Nobody has returned any keys.
You,
if you want to check back later and giggling at,
rarely.
Rarely am I really gonna come back later.
You know,
I'm not going to come back later.
So just spare me the speech,
right.
Just go fucking change the chances of fire sign out there.
Why don't you just go fucking do that.
You're like,
oh man.
At the park ranger because I ran with my AMF fucking sweat pants with the sides.
Unzipped like an asshole.
Like a fucking asshole.
All right.
Last week I talked about this guy who I wanted to uh,
flattened his nose while I sent my fist all the way to the back of his fucking
cranium stopping just short of the hypothalamus and I was talking about fights
and uh,
just how when you get older you have to walk away from fights because there's no
winning.
There really isn't.
When you get old,
it's just like,
okay,
either a,
I get out of the car and I get the living shit kicked out of me.
Right?
Or B,
I win and then I get sued.
Right.
And the older you get,
the the,
the greater chance of the first one,
which is,
I don't know.
What do you think's worse?
Getting the shit kicked out of you?
I think getting sued is worse,
but as long as it depends on the,
the level of ass kicking.
I don't want to lose a tooth,
but you know,
if you want to beat me down,
I have a headache for three days.
I'd rather have that than deal with you.
Fucking taken my money.
So anyways.
Um,
so a lot of people sent me in some unbelievable stories about fights that either
they walked away from or that they got into.
I'm one of them is actually a case pending,
so I'm not allowed to talk about it.
So I'll basically,
I'll skim over it is basically a kid is walking down the street and three drunk
guys start giving him shit.
He gives him shit back.
They give him some more shit and he says,
Oh yeah,
you guys are real tough with three.
None of you would fight me one on one and this one kid goes,
all right,
I'll fight you.
So they square off,
they'd throw a few in the dough.
The kid who was just part of,
you know,
the,
the innocent kid connected hit the kid.
The kid falls down and hits the back of his head on the pavement.
He,
you know,
and he's not fucking moving.
And the kid's like,
holy fuck,
what did I do?
So he's kind of walking away,
but he's also concerned,
his big fucking mistake was he actually gave a shit and then the cops showed up.
He was still in sight.
He got fucking,
uh,
did they arrest him?
I can't remember.
All I know was in the end of it,
this,
there's three of them and only one of him.
And he ended up getting sued and lost something about a preemptive strike.
Can you fucking believe that?
I was like,
Oh,
I'm sorry.
Was I supposed to let the one guy with the two other friends hit me a couple
times and then I was supposed to punch back is fucking unbelievable.
It's unbelievable.
Just A,
I don't know.
So there was a lot of people going like,
oh,
I want to kick the shit out of this guy.
What should I do?
You know what you should do?
We should just fucking walk away.
Just walk away and just forget about the whole fucking thing.
And don't even tell yourself that lie that he'll get his,
he'll get his,
cause you know what,
they don't,
they don't get there.
So you know what they do is they get punched in the face,
may be in the worst case scenario is they win 10 grand.
Um,
they don't,
they don't.
I,
I've lived long enough to realize that,
you know,
when the bad guy gets his in the movies,
that's when it happens.
Okay.
The rest of them go on to live very successful lives.
They have great looking girlfriends.
They a porous,
raw sewage into drinking water and they find some other Dick to take the fall
for it.
And then they buy land in South America and they leave the country and they're
fine.
They're fucking find.
So,
uh,
you're better to just,
just walk away.
Somebody gave me some great advice saying that,
uh,
the,
he used to get into fights all the time.
This is so simple.
I never even thought of it.
He just bought a heavy bag and he would come home and he would just beat the
shit out of the bag and he felt way better and there was no lawsuits.
And then certain days when he wanted to murder somebody,
he would take a baseball bat and just slam it into the heavy bag.
And he would feel phenomenal afterwards.
And,
uh,
I,
I liked,
I want to,
I want to believe that that works.
I don't know.
I have an insane temper.
I take it to the point of,
I want to feel that other guy quit.
That's how mad I am.
I want to beat the fuck out of you.
I want you to fight back,
but I want to feel the moment where you fucking quit.
You know how sick is that?
That's how mad.
I just can't see that getting that out with the fucking heavy bag.
All right,
so let's read a couple of stories here.
These were very long.
This was a very passionate subject.
Um,
so forgive me with my awful reading here goes,
I'm gonna read a couple of these.
Um,
all right.
Uh,
here's,
here's the classic like this.
This is like anger that will come out of you 20 years from now.
Here's a great story here.
Uh,
Bill,
I sympathize about the whole fight thing.
Um,
it seems like anytime some asshole decides to start shit with me,
it will happen in a war in a way that I can't retaliate without either getting
arrested or sued.
Literally what I was just talking about.
He goes,
so anyways,
I was at a packed bar with some friends the other night and uh,
we had gotten there about a half hour prior and I had about a one beer in me,
so I wasn't even remotely drunk.
Um,
I guess the place was packed.
So anyways,
he's a,
she says,
I was making my way through the crowd with a pint glass in my hand trying to
navigate to the bathroom along the way,
some scrawny little cunt who apparently has had way too much to drink,
backs into me and spills half my beer and make a habit out of quickly saying,
excuse me,
and thank you whenever I walk through a crowd because I figure people are more
apt to let you through if you're polite about things.
This prick turns around and says,
this is the guy who,
who bumps into him and spills half as his beer.
He said,
this prick turns around and says,
what the fuck is your problem?
And knocks my drink out of my hand.
Jesus Christ.
You ought to be able to take a fucking wrench to that guy's head.
Um,
he said at this point,
one of his friends jumps on him trying to break it up while the little bitch
keeps talking shit.
So I tell them to go fuck himself.
It was going to talk shit till the prick would,
uh,
would throw a punch.
But just at that moment,
a guy standing next to us wearing a blazer but with some kind of shirt sweater
that was,
that wasn't buttoned down,
tells me forcefully keep walking.
At that moment I figured it was one of the bouncers pissed off over having lost
a drink and being insulted.
Uh,
I head to the bathroom,
my window to fight.
That shit had open and closed so quickly that I didn't get a chance at any
vindication.
When I got to the bathroom,
I noticed that the guy who I thought was a bouncer was it,
um,
maybe he was,
maybe he was this little clowns,
a bodyguard,
but I couldn't tell.
He didn't seem like one,
he didn't seem like one of his friends because the little cut in his friends
were all dressed the same way with designer ripped jeans and opened button down
shirts with necklaces and shit.
Basically they all look like they were members of some eighties rock band that
was still touring but couldn't get but can only get gigs in a dive bar.
Um,
now my chance,
my choices are either,
okay,
now he's in the bathroom.
Uh,
he says,
now my choices are either walked back to my group without a beer
or a the bitch move of telling one of the bouncers and seeing if I can get that
prick tossed out.
Um,
I could also go and confront them,
but even if I could take the bodyguard,
um,
what kind of person goes to a bar dressed with that ed?
The clothing with the girl.
What did I just miss here?
Sorry.
This is really fucking long and I'm seeing double here.
Ah,
fuck.
You just killed the whole story bill.
What is wrong with you?
Confront him,
which from his size,
I think I stared a good chance as long he was an MMA fighter.
Uh,
this was in New Jersey.
Mind you.
So I thought,
uh,
I thought considering he was Italian looking and had a girl that was way out of
his league,
maybe he was connected or some bullshit like that.
Maybe a,
the little prick even had a gun or a knife on him because stupid shit like that
is happening off thing.
I didn't want to take any shit from him,
but I'm not about to get shot over a beer anyways.
It's,
so this is what he ends up doing.
He goes,
ended up walking back to my group without a beer and hiding my bad mood for the
rest of the night.
One on one with either one of those cons,
I would've been fine.
I'm five,
1,195 pounds and mostly muscle and I've never lost a fight.
Then again,
I've only been in a few.
I'll spare the rest of this shit.
Um,
I don't know if he's asking me what I can't even remember.
I just,
I get a headache when I have to read that much,
so,
you know what I mean?
It's like,
and do you think that little,
maybe that little fuck,
we'll get his because he's so like I could see knocking it over and be like,
dude,
what the fuck's your problem?
That's sort of your average asshole in a bar,
but then slap it out of your hand.
He's got that Napoleon thing where he's got something to prove,
I guess.
Um,
I don't know.
My question is,
what do you do with that anger?
What do you do with that fucking anger?
Anyways,
here's an alarm bill.
Uh,
you were talking about this week about nearly getting into a fight with that
Dick and the green sedan.
Well,
I admit that this wasn't anywhere close to me fighting.
It was still a fucking horror story while it happened.
All right,
here's one here that will leave you with a lot of anger.
Uh,
I was about six months into my standup career in a friend of mine asked me to do
,
to do a show with him at this bar that paid them a,
that pay would pay $20.
I was psyched because it would be my first paid show.
I did the show and got a decent amount of laughs.
I thought I did fucking horribly,
but uh,
if they left and I'm not going to complain.
So he gets paid his money.
The next day I'm walking,
I'm walking home from school and I'm cutting through the basketball courts where
a drug dealer,
I know we'll call him drug dealer number one is sitting there with one of his
friends,
the friends he was sitting with kind of look like ghost face killer,
but he had a stare of a potential rapist.
Next thing I know I'm passing this guy and he stops me.
He tells me that if I don't give him my wallet,
which is visible,
which was visibly in my front pocket,
he was going to just stop me and take it.
He takes it and empties my lunch money.
Luckily,
or I thought,
luckily I kept a special 20 and a different compartment.
Now this is a lot of things a lot of comedians do or people who when they,
they set off on a dream,
the first amount of money they get,
it's usually not a lot of money.
So they either frame the check or they save the dollar,
the five bucks of the 20.
So I'm imagining that this is what this young comic was trying to do.
So we kept a $20 in the,
in a different compartment.
I said,
well,
he rummaged through the entire wallet,
put back my Larb library card,
the illiterate cunt,
and eventually found a $20 bill.
He threw the wallet my chest and asked me why I lied to him when he asked me if
I had any other money than any other money than the lunch money.
I actually told the guy mugging me the history of this hidden $20 bill as he
goes.
As I just typed that last sentence,
I just imagine my head slamming into the keyboard.
Um,
he says,
what a,
what a fag.
I was,
um,
so anyways,
this motherfucker told me that if I told them a good joke,
maybe I'd get the $20 back.
This is really your inexperience as a comedian because there's no joke you're
going to be able to tell.
So anyways,
here we go.
He said,
well,
I used to tell these awful one liners when I first started because my self
confidence would dwindle left at 10 to 15 seconds.
So I stammered out,
stammered out.
I knew this girl is so stupid.
The only reason why she knew her ABC's was because of hepatitis.
So then the drug dealer,
he fake laughed like a fucking maniac,
straightened up into a serious face and was just like,
get the fuck Outta here.
Wow.
Ah,
Jesus.
That'll age you about fucking eight years.
Anyways,
the rest of it,
needless to say,
I took it like a bitch,
but if this story didn't have a punchline in and of itself,
here's the kicker.
Literally less than a week later after this incident,
this drug dealer from,
from my school,
big black kid with a voice like Mickey Mouse.
It's a fucking spectacle.
A tells me that drug dealer,
number one,
stop hanging out with the ghost face.
Killer guy because he's an undercover fucking cop.
So this dude got mugged by an undercover fucking cop.
So for all you,
for all your talk about getting screwed by corporations,
that's the worst case of being deep dicked by the man that's ever happened to
me.
And then I realized in retrospect that even though I lost the first remanence of
what I'd hope B would be a successful career,
the losing of my first $20 was well worth the story.
I still hope that cop is shot in the line of duty,
in skull fucked by a gang of junkies.
See that?
That's the fucking anger.
That is the anger.
Um,
I dunno,
I don't know how many listeners I have at this point cause I don't really hight
this fucking thing and I never bring it up at shows.
Are there any,
uh,
psychologists out there?
You know,
psychologists like they know what to do with anger is fucking sweater wearing
douchebags just sitting there.
They're loafers.
He ever go to therapy,
he's fucking tell him shit and they're just like,
whoa.
What do you think?
You think that,
what would happen if you would do something like that?
It's just like,
it really is.
That's all you got.
You know,
they just basically get you to pour out all your shit and then you've got to
sort of figure it out.
I don't even what the f you know,
it's fucking hilarious.
I had been in therapy for a while now obviously it's not fucking working.
I'm anyways,
let's plow ahead here.
Um,
did I talk about this last week?
Somebody sent me a,
uh,
somebody sent,
oh,
somebody sent me a,
an email and was talking about my why and then like now I hope this,
this podcast has been loud enough.
I think it is.
Um,
somebody sent me an email talking about some new movie coming out and in the
subject,
the thing,
the,
the line in the movie,
the lion on the subject line said,
um,
another save the black kid movie and it said bill from various clips on Youtube.
I know you have some disdain for racist movies.
I was just wondering,
what's your feeling on the new one coming out with Sandra Bullock called the
blind side?
I guess it's about her helping some,
a black kid.
All right.
First of all,
this is what I love about this email is,
um,
and this is something that I've learned in standup comedy is you had,
you can't control how people process what you say.
Um,
I've never done a bit about another about save a black kid movies.
The name of the bit was,
uh,
white people are evil movies.
That's what it is.
And,
um,
I don't have,
obviously I have disdained for racist movies,
but like what the fuck movie was I talking about in my last special,
that one about the black swim team.
Uh,
what the fuck was it called?
Poolside.
I can't ever remember.
What was it called against the tide?
The fuck was that movie called whatever,
whatever that fucking movie was called chlorine.
What was it called?
Did that shock for like fucking a year on stage?
If you guys seen that new movie came out,
blah,
blah.
I can't,
I'm trying to jog if my life,
I,
I have no memory.
But anyways,
that movie is not an example of a racist movie.
That's a movie about race.
And,
uh,
I have,
you know,
this is just a podcast listener.
So what the food,
you know,
I'm not really going to give this guy shit about that,
but I've actually had people write reviews about my act and says,
and was describing some of the stuff I talked to be talks about the difference
between men and women.
Uh,
he does racist jokes.
He does Bababa Blah.
It's like,
I don't do I do racial jokes about race or racial jokes?
A movie about race is a,
is a,
you could say it's a,
I guess a racial movie or,
yeah,
you'd say that it's not racist.
A racist movie would be,
um,
I dunno.
What's a fucking good example of it?
What does it good?
I mean,
Mississippi burning is not a racist movie.
It's a movie about racist.
But the movie itself is not racist,
but race relations,
right.
My out of my fucking mind here,
that,
what's that fucking one of the original Hollywood movies where they have white
dudes dressed up in black face and then make it black people look stupid.
And that is the message of the movie.
They're not,
they're not doing a movie.
They're making fun of white people who do that are talking about why people who
do that,
they are.
That is the message of the movie.
That black people are stupid.
That is a fucking racist movie.
See the difference?
What the fuck is the name of that movie?
Did you begin with an h?
I have no,
I gotta stop talking on my cell phone.
I'm,
you know what I'm not doing.
I'm fuck my cell phone.
That's it.
It's over.
All right.
The fuck is the name of that movie.
All right,
but get it.
Forget it.
I fucking give up.
I have to fucking,
ah,
I gotta look it up now guys,
this is something,
if you can hear it,
my voice,
this is actually something that's fucking scare in me,
is that I'm starting to lose my God damn memory.
Some actually made an ah,
the fuck is it?
Okay,
now
you know what?
Where the fuck is it?
I really should edit all this out,
but I'm not gonna do it.
I'm not going to do it.
Why am I saying everything twice?
You know why?
Because I'm trying to find something that somebody sent me.
They sent me a nice little MP3 remix of the thing and I had it all queued up and
I can't fucking find it.
You fucking asshole bill.
You really are an asshole.
You fucking worthless.
And this is why you have to fly out to fucking Omaha at some point and tell some
jokes.
You know I had last week I made fun of Omaha saying how I wasn't going to do a
show in Omaha and people were like,
you know,
I said eventually I would do one,
but I was making fun of how many fucking airplanes I would have to take to get
there and I got like five emails from people.
Actually there's a direct flight from book and Gig or dirt or do you really need
to no fucking corn field and you can just say it up fucking stage right bucket
in there.
Bill people in Omaha don't talk like that.
I don't give a shit.
I know they don't.
Johnny Carson was from Nebraska,
wasn't he?
All I remember about Nebraska was doing college gigs out there and you drive
halfway across the state and in your driving across 80 which goes the length of
this,
uh,
east west.
Here's something that truckers know.
Do you guys know this shit?
You know if you're on in an even numbered highway,
that means it goes east,
west.
And if you're on a odd one,
that means it's north south.
Did you know that?
Huh?
I'm talking about highways.
So don't even hit me with though we're route one goes really shut up.
Not talking about roots.
I'm talking about highways is another thing.
If you're on,
if you're on a highway,
right?
Let's just say it's 95 and you don't have a map all right in your,
and you see all of a sudden there's a four 95 or eight to 95 what that means is
you are coming towards a congested area and if it's during rush hour,
you can jump on the to 95 or the four 95 and it will basically eventually re
hook up with the highway.
You're on 95 and you can avoid the traffic.
And not add to it.
They did that one for truckers.
Um,
it's like an la,
the four oh five you got the five goes right to the heart of La,
the four oh five when it goes out around Santa Monica.
But there's so many fucking people,
it doesn't make a difference out here cause they're all jammed.
All right.
That's how much I know this fuck.
That's how much road work I've done.
So you get on the fucking 80 and you get about halfway across Nebraska.
And if you're like me,
you're doing a college gig in the middle of the winter time.
So all the crops are cut down.
All right?
And you can't tell where the fucking dirt ends in the sky begins.
It's just all fucking gray.
And all of a sudden,
out of nowhere there's like this wooden bridge footbridge or some native
American Indian shit.
You know,
I just,
you know,
many times I drove underneath that,
I don't even know what the fuck it is racing back to either flying out of
Lincoln or Omaha trying to get back to catch my early flight.
And I would literally be driving like a maniac and I be looking out to the right
and there would literally be like a flock of geese in that V,
that v formation.
You know the one that daffy duck was like,
fuck this.
I'm not going snow flies.
Don't bother me.
Remember that one?
I'd be seeing that shit.
I drove 80 I believe.
I drove 80 in Wyoming and I saw a kind of antelope.
I don't even know what the fuck it was.
I had no idea what the fuck it was.
Just saw like species of animals that I didn't even know fucking existed in this
country.
70 I remember 70 I've drove.
I've driven that one all the way from la all the way right into New York City.
You get it all the way to about Jersey and then you've got a fucking switch it
up.
It's fucking brutal.
Ben On all of them,
90 95
I think.
What is 35 go from Houston right up to Dallas and that fucking insane.
Then all of a sudden the years later I'd be up in IB in in like Iowa.
Go.
Now,
this is the same fucking highway that you take from fucking Houston to Dallas
and it goes right at the heart of this fucking country.
Isn't that fucking interesting?
Um,
yeah.
A lot of fucking road work.
I was supposed to be searching for the email and actually just lean back
thinking about those fucking days being out,
you know,
many times I did Coosbay Oregon I think like three or four fucking times.
Every time I went down there,
the goddamned seals,
whenever out they had this thing where you could actually see the seals sunning
themselves,
which was fucking amazing to me at that point because I lived on the,
I lived on the east coast,
you know,
when the fuck do you get a chance to see that,
I just cannot,
I cannot find this fucking thing.
I have to find you this,
this clip,
this person send this MP three he did a remix to a song.
I'm trying to kill time because I can't fucking find it.
Hey Bill.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Read this shit cunt.
This is what,
these are the emails I get from you guys.
That's not it.
File recommendation.
Shithead bar fight story.
Oh yeah.
It's a,
it's a mission.
Now
give me something else to talk about.
He got anything,
any questions?
This is when I,
it kills me that I,
that I don't,
I don't have any callers because this is what the fuck happened.
I'm quitting after two more emails I have,
you know,
it's something going to be worth it by the time I find it.
It's in the payoff.
It's not going to be worth it.
Hey,
did the Phillies win tonight?
Please tell me they won.
I've never given a fuck about the Phillies until now.
I just can't stomach the fucking Lakers and the Yankees are gonna win it this
year.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
Jesus Christ to fucking Yankees.
What a team.
Huh?
What a fucking team.
A Rod,
Rodney third jade or at said that Jesus Christ,
Jesus Christ covers up to the plate and the Yankee son and for one year,
yeah,
actually,
uh,
they actually is suspended there.
No facial hair rule with him.
Johnny is a little upset,
but you know he is the son of God fucking cunt.
You fucking rich.
[inaudible] he called that an accomplishment.
You won a world series.
What?
Cause you got the most fucking money.
There is no,
there's no skill in that.
There's no fucking skill in that.
You fucking pieces of shit and they actually have,
you know what?
I can't stand on my Yankee fans.
They actually have the nerve to be nervous during the playoffs when they cut to
the crowd and like,
oh Geez,
I hope this hundred million guy can do it.
If he doesn't do it,
maybe to share her,
we'll deal with it.
You fucking cops.
You know I hit about the fucking Yankees.
Whoever beats them the year before,
whoever the best guy is,
within two years,
he's on the team to share a beat them last year with the fucking angels.
Now he's on playing first base.
I've already bitched about this shit.
Who gives a fuck?
Right?
It's just fucking baseball.
You know what I've been actually doing?
I've been watching the NHL network.
I actually just watched something about the 1979 Montreal Canadians winning the
Stanley Cup.
You know what the worst thing about watching the kitties win the Stanley Cup
back then is you knew that there was going to be some sort of heartbreaking
Boston Bruins lost and 79 I was too young to remember it,
but I just remember people bitching about it.
We basically beat the Canadians for games to three and then with like a minute
left they called too many men on the ice,
which is basically,
uh,
I'm trying to think of the fucking,
it's,
you know,
like in football when somebody,
a kicks,
somebody calls for a fair catch and you've got to give like five yards,
you've got to give the guy five yards so he can catch it.
And I,
you know,
people break it all the time.
They never call it if the other defensive player gets in face that that's like
calling,
making that call with one minute left to decide who goes to the Stanley Cup
finals and then the fucking fly French fucks ended up scoring a goal and then
they got the overtime goal.
It was just fucking annoying.
It was annoying to watch,
but they did beat the rangers.
So that made me feel good.
Um,
I think that's it guys.
I can't find this fucking thing.
This guy did a remix of that song,
uh,
that,
that data bup,
bup,
banner Bailyn hat,
hat,
hat.
He did a remix of that.
Me saying count count,
count.
And I thought it was cute
and I just feel like for me,
I can't find it.
What was better?
The fact that just sang it for you was that decent.
All right.
I give up.
That's it.
Jesus Christ.
What a fucking horrific podcast.
But you know what?
I did get it out Monday morning.
You know what?
I want to thank everybody.
I've been getting a ton of emails about people.
Uh,
I've got a letter from a postman who just walks around listening to my podcast
as he delivers the mail laughing like a maniac.
That's what everybody keeps telling me.
They keep listening to them when they're supposed to be doing their job and
they're just sitting there laughing like a fucking maniac.
So why?
I know this one was a little fucked up.
The volume was messed up,
but that's what you get.
That's what you get.
Somebody sent me an email going like,
you know what?
I'm so pissed.
I've been listening to Opie and Anthony for awhile and I had no idea that you a
podcast.
What the fuck?
This is what he said.
He said,
I've been a fan for several years.
Uh,
duty.
Your appearances on the OPN,
Anthony Show,
uh,
being the lazy shitbag than I am.
I've never checked out your website until a week ago.
How has the podcast not mentioned on Opie and Anthony?
They actually,
they have mentioned it.
Um,
but he said a,
do they forbid that or something?
No,
they do not.
But he said,
I guess it's none of my business anyway,
but I'm pisses me off.
You've been doing it this long,
two plus years,
and now I'm just finding out about it.
I've already listened to the last three months of podcast and we'll continue
back until I've heard them all.
Um,
you're,
you're really funny guy and it's a shame this podcast is flying under the radar.
Well,
I say this to you.
It is not a shame that it's flying under the radar.
I liked that.
It is,
I don't hype it.
You find it.
If you don't,
it's like fight club.
Right.
Except you don't have to be a Badass.
First rule about the podcast is not that you don't talk about it.
All right?
You know what the first rule is?
Is that you don't take the podcast seriously.
That's what it is.
Like this fucking guy tore me a new asshole about rugby because I was shitting
on rugby.
This fucking guy sends me this whole,
we are a few weeks ago you made some disparaging remarks about rugby is compared
to American football ever stopped to think about how we'll look illogical and
ludicrous.
It is to call it football when you don't use your foot.
He's giving me like Jerry Seinfeld Shit.
If memory serves,
you said something to effect that those rugby pussies would be getting,
wouldn't be getting up if ray Lewis put a hit on him.
You know what dude,
I stand by that statement but uh,
I know I already answered you email,
but for all you fucking lie me cuts over there and fucking England.
The reason why I shit on rugby was because the English country who wrote me was
shitting all over fucking American sports.
So obviously you're not going to treat me with respect.
I'm going to make fun of fucking rugby and your little booty short,
Larry Bird short shorts from the 19 fucking eighties,
and how every fucking 10 minutes.
You have to basically stick your head up some,
uh,
somebody else's ass as you guys tried to do that elephant trick of kicking the
ball out the back.
Totally respect rugby.
I think it's a fucking awesome game.
I've seen it on TV.
It is the shit and they have literally bone jarring lose.
You're filling fucking hits all the time.
I do think it's a great sport.
I do think people are tough,
but you know,
if you're going to shit on American football,
I'm going to shit all over your sports.
That's how it works.
Please do not take the podcast seriously.
I don't fucking read.
I do it by myself.
As you can tell what the different levels of volume this week.
I'm not organized.
All right,
so that's the one and only rule.
All right.
Don't take it seriously.
And if you can remember,
tell somebody in if not,
don't,
because I think the smaller this thing stays the cooler it's going to be named
one fucking thing that is blown up and stayed at the same level of quality.
It doesn't,
it doesn't,
you know,
you want,
I want it to be like this.
I want to fucking,
I'm gonna be down in the Fox hole.
You know,
if I,
if I had this thing actually ever fucking blew up and I'm,
I'm,
I'm doing rants about saying unacceptable than these fucking other cons,
we'll figure out that.
That's what we're saying.
We're saying unacceptable.
Then the whole game plan is over,
and then what I'm doing here is fucking useless.
Right.
Wow.
Did I just go off in a fantasy there where this thing became the biggest fucking
radio show ever?
I think I just did.
You know,
that's what happens when you sit here by yourself.
You'll let your dreams leak out and then people make funny you and then you feel
silly.
Um,
all right.
That's the podcast for this week.
That was a fucking mess.
All right.
It was a fucking mess.
I'm gonna,
you know,
I think it kinda got back on the rails afterwards,
but it was a message you guys ever,
we were on ESPN first came out and they used to sell those fucking rednecks.
They'd race in the murdered member that they turn their tractors into these,
uh,
I don't know what the fuck they were,
but they would,
they would race through the Mug,
did get bogged down.
That's what the fuck it was.
I was at redneck sitting in that tractor in the mud.
I like how I had to explain that it's sucked.
Like he didn't fucking notice.
Um,
that's it.
All you guys have a great fucking week.
And,
um,
that's it.
That's the podcast for this week.
And I've,
uh,
talked myself into a corner once again because I usually end with have a great
week.
That's what I usually say.
And then I continued talking and now here I am down in the fucking murder again.
Um,
hey,
has anybody seen that come?
I'm just gonna keep talking.
If you guys seen that commercial where they got the fucking,
uh,
they're trying to help you out of that financial,
you know,
all these people in financial difficulties.
Um,
AH,
fuck.
That's what I was going to talk about.
God dammit.
No one's listening at this point.
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna waste this story.
I went to the supermarket.
Okay.
And I don't use those little savy saved cards that they have Yammer,
a little SAIDI saved card.
And I always say,
no,
would you like one?
No,
I wouldn't,
you know,
because basically what you're doing is a free fucking survey.
Remember that shit so they can figure out what you can't live without.
So they can jack up the price of that food and then give you like Dan Nicola
like,
uh,
their version of corn flakes.
So I went in there,
okay.
And they asked me if I had to sit in their little safe card and I said no.
And he said,
do you want one?
I said,
no.
And The lady goes,
it's okay.
I'll just punch in a code anyways.
So she punches in a code and I get money off anyways.
So it's like they even figured out a way to figure out what I'm fucking buying,
even when I'm saying go fuck yourself to the save thing.
So I think the only way to get around it at this point,
I'm going to try it next time is I'm going to walk in with cash.
And just have cash and see what the fuck they do.
You know,
they did it to me today at Macy's.
I went out there and I bought some towels and I bought some beer glasses.
That's what I bought Macy's.
And they say,
do you ever,
do you have a Macy's card?
I said,
no,
I don't.
It will give you 25% off every douchey thing you bought.
I said,
that's okay.
And she goes,
it's all right.
I'll give you the discount anyways.
And she types in this fucking code.
I don't know what they're up to.
I really don't know what they're up to,
but I know they don't sit around trying to make less money.
Does anybody know what the fuck that's about?
That is your homework for this week.
If you still listened,
if you listened this far,
you fucking hate your job and you need to get a new one.
All right?
Don't hurt anybody at work.
All right,
that's it.
Now I'm done.
Everybody have a good week.
I'll talk to you next.
[inaudible]
Oh,
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible].